The Scarlet King is a really bad guy.
He’s a giant, interdimensional Nightmare
God, intent on breaching our reality and wreaking
terrible havoc on everything we know and love.
He’s been responsible for untold suffering
and chaos across countless worlds, timelines,
and layers of reality.
To many, he’s even somewhat of a “Final
Boss” to the SCP Foundation.
And just when you think he couldn’t get
any worse, it turns out that he’s also a
deadbeat dad.
Not only did the Scarlet King once have a
cult literally named The Children of the Scarlet
King, before it was destroyed by Dr. Montauk
and the SCP Foundation, he also had at least
seven actual children.
Each one is speculated to be a powerful anomaly,
but it’s tough to find concrete answers
as to who, or what exactly, most of them are.
So today we’re putting on our researcher
hats and digging deep into the Foundation
lore, to present our theories on the potential
progeny of the SCP Foundation’s greatest
enemy.
And if nothing else, we might finally be able
to get this dark lord of all evil to start
paying all the child support he probably owes
by now.
First, if you’re not well-versed in Scarlet
King lore, you may be wondering: How exactly
does an Evil Chaos God have kids?
Is there a Scarlet Queen out there who prefers
to stay out of the limelight?
The answer isn’t quite that simple, and
it has everything to do with SCP-231 and Big
Red’s most devoted cult, the non-biological
Children of the Scarlet King.
They kidnapped a group of seven girls, and
performed a number of dark rituals that resulted
in them becoming vessels for the Scarlet King’s
Seven Terrible Kids.
These seven girls have become known as SCP-231.
Anyone who accesses those files - and trust
us, that they aren’t a pretty sight - will
find that containment procedures mostly involved
performing the infamous Montauk Procedure
on the surviving girls to keep them from giving
birth.
Six of the seven brides have given birth to
nightmares beyond comprehension and are now
dead, with only one still remaining successfully
contained.
But here at the SCP Foundation, you need to
learn to comprehend the incomprehensible.
According to a classified document, SCP-231
may technically be a neutralized anomaly without
us even knowing.
And incidentally, this gives us our most certain
answer on the Children of the Scarlet King.
On this one, the apple fell very, very far
from the tree.
According to the secret document, SCP-999
- that’s right, the adorable tickle monster
- is the seventh child of the Scarlet King.
He must be so disappointed that everyone’s
favorite little blob didn’t want to join
the family business of Absolute Evil.
For anyone who doesn’t know, SCP-999 is
a slimy, yellow entity that only seems capable
of absolute compassion.
It brings joy to everyone in its presence,
and with prolonged exposure, it can even cure
disorders like PTSD, anxiety, and depression.
He’s so good at this that he even cured
SCP-231-7 - his de facto mother - of her trauma,
and allowed her to return happily to her family
after some amnestic treatment.
The Scarlet King has another good reason to
be ashamed of his cheerful, blobby son: Ancient
Daevite prophecy dictates that SCP-999 may
someday become so powerful that his force
of absolute love and good overwhelms the Scarlet
King’s evil and chaos.
Think of him as the Luke Skywalker to the
Scarlet King’s Darth Vader, though we probably
can’t expect a cool lightsaber battle between
them any time soon.
How disappointing.
So if SCP-999 is the quiet, sensitive, black
sheep of the Scarlet Family, who’s the golden
child who makes his evil father proud?
The real chip off the old block?
That would be our dear, reptilian friend SCP-682,
the malicious lizard heavily implied to be
a child of the Scarlet King.
If you know literally anything about 682,
your reaction to finding out he’s the spawn
of cruelty personified is probably, “Yeah,
that makes sense.”
Just as SCP-999 is the Scarlet King’s innocent,
optimistic young child, 682 is kind of like
his edgy teenager, still in the middle of
a misanthropic phase he shows no sign of leaving
anytime soon.
The fact that 682 appears to find everything
about the world around him utterly disgusting
seems to be a trait he inherited from his
dear old Dad, and the fact he seems pretty
much impossible to kill also lends credence
to the popular theory he’s got Nightmare
God Blood running through his veins.
682 has also started displaying a particular
hatred for 999 ever since an incident where
999 tickled him into submission, so family
dinners are probably extra awkward for these
two.
999 and 682 are the most certain children,
but that still leaves us with five more children
to identify.
It’s worth remembering that the waters are
murkier from here on in, but we’ve searched
far and wide through the Foundation Archives
to find possible answers.
If your interpretation differs, remember that
it’s just a theory - an SCP Explained Theory.
Thankfully, we do have some assistance here:
The tale Dust and Blood hinted at what each
of the seven children of the Scarlet King
represents, and that may help us narrow down
our choices here.
To put things into perspective, it’s believed
that 682 was the fourth child to be born,
representing Wrath.
And 999 was the seventh, representing Hope.
According to this tale, the first of the seven
children represents Dominion, and as a result,
is skilled in the ways of war and has the
power to lead the King’s forces to victory.
According to one Foundation theorist, this
child could potentially be SCP-239, also known
as the Witch Child.
This entity is so powerful that, as part of
its containment procedures, it’s eternally
kept in a coma.
Why?
Because this seemingly normal child has dominion
over reality, and can change it to her whims.
Her thoughts are so powerful that just her
brain waves can damage physical matter, and
she can make things disappear or manifest
in an instant.
She’s also almost impossible to kill, with
skin that’s almost totally impenetrable.
Much like SCP-682, she’s also frighteningly
strong in both the offense and defense department.
We’re talking about such a powerful telepath
that Dr. Clef has campaigned for her immediate
termination, just because it’s safer that
way.
This is certainly a frightening wunderkind
that the Scarlet King would be proud to call
his daughter.
Next, the second child.
According to the prophecy, this child represents
“Longing.”
The child has the power to bring forth armies,
which will help the Scarlet King in his conquest.
For this, we actually have a pretty unconventional
theory: SCP-029, otherwise known as the Daughter
of Darkness.
If the name alone wasn’t enough to suggest
that she’s got an extremely sinister father,
she also fits the profile of being very aggressive
and incredibly hard to kill.
But even more damning is her connections to
the symbology of “Longing”: One of her
most dangerous powers is causing men to fall
into almost trancelike devotion to her.
After spending time around her, they’re
suddenly willing to murder in her honor - strangling
their victims in hopes of raising Kali, the
Hindu god of destruction, whom has many similarities
to the Scarlet King.
She certainly fits the bill of someone capable
of raising armies in the dark lord’s name.
One strike against our Scarlet King connection
theory is that the file states the Daughter
of Darkness was first discovered in India,
which wouldn’t match up with the other information
we know to be fact.
However, while this is a long shot, given
the sensitive nature of everything involving
the Scarlet King, it’s extremely possible
that false information was supplied to bury
the connection.
Considering the coverups and lies involving
anomalies like SCP-1000, this certainly isn’t
an unprecedented move on the part of the Foundation.
Next, the third child.
This child is associated with all things “Desolation”,
implying destruction, fire, ashes, pestilence,
and death across the battlefield.
When it comes to spreading destruction and
death on a mass scale, one particular SCP
comes to mind: SCP-058, the Heart of Darkness.
This creature has Scarlet King written all
over it: It’s evil, it’s mysterious, it’s
pretty much impossible to kill, and it causes
mass casualties every time it escapes its
containment chamber.
It causes fires, whips people to death with
its razor-sharp tendrils, and sprays highly
corrosive acid from its scorpion-like tail.
And it’s even red!
Given that we know for a fact this entity
suddenly emerged out of something that’s
now been expunged from the records in an undisclosed
site, it’s extremely possible that the entity
058 came from was SCP-231-3.
This is a child that the Scarlet King would
definitely be proud of, given that it’s
impossible to reason with, and feels solely
motivated by causing destruction, misery,
and chaos.
We can’t think of any entity that better
suits the “Desolation” moniker than SCP-058.
Next - skipping past SCP-682 at number four
- the fifth child of the Scarlet King is associated
with the loose concept of “Lack.”
The prophecy then goes into more detail, saying
that this child is powerful in the ways of
magic, and is able to use their abilities
to cause great destruction.
Here, we have another unconventional proposal:
What if child number four wasn’t actually
a child, but children?
That’s because we think this description
perfectly fits SCP-1765, the nightmarish,
reality warping Sisters, who we think may
actually be triplets of the Scarlet King’s
fifth bride.
Hear us out: These are actually some of the
most powerful enemies the Foundation has ever
attempted to contain, and we know nothing
about their past before being bound to a few
objects by the Serpent’s Hand.
These sadistic reality warpers are so devastatingly
powerful that the only action the Foundation
can take against them is letting them have
free reign over the containment site they
currently inhabit.
All the Foundation can do is hope they never
get bored of tormenting the people inside.
As we all know, the Scarlet King despises
science, progress, and order, so perhaps a
perfect punishment for the Foundation in his
many eyes is giving them a taste of their
own medicine.
The Sisters, though particularly their ringleader,
are a perverse shadow of the Foundation’s
love of the scientific method.
They take these methods and use them for an
activity that the Scarlet King finds much
more enjoyable: Tormenting and killing people.
Whenever these crafty triplets set their mind
to it, their horrifically powerful magic is
able to cause massive devastation - just like
the prophecy for the fifth bride’s offspring
dictates.
And finally, the sixth child of the Scarlet
King.
The concept associated with this one is “Hidden”,
meaning it can change its face and walk unnoticed
through creation.
It’s also said to have the responsibility
of opening the ways between worlds, and allowing
the war to end all wars to first begin.
There have been a huge number of guesses for
this spot, with some even suggesting SCP-055
- the Anti-Meme - but since we’re having
fun here, we want to make an even wilder suggestion.
We posit that the sixth child of the Scarlet
King is Alison Chao, also known as L.S. and
The Black Queen, the most powerful member
of the Serpent’s Hand.
We get it, we have a lot of explaining to
do, but hear us out.
Alison Chao is a member of the Serpent’s
Hand, or technically, many members.
Multiple versions of her exist across parallel
dimensions in the SCP Multiverse - They’re
mostly all estranged daughters of Foundation
researcher, Dr. Charles Gears.
This estrangement leads them to collaborate
in the Wanderer’s Library, the secret base
of the Serpent’s Hand, to conduct raids
on the Foundation in revenge.
But what if the leader of these alternate
Alisons had an ulterior motive, because - in
the infinite number of possibilities offered
by the multiverse - this one was not the daughter
of Charles Gears, but the Scarlet King.
She’s merely using the pain of her counterparts
to manipulate them into accomplishing her
true father’s goal: Undermining the SCP
Foundation.
Let’s break it down: The “Hidden” child
is prophesied to walk unnoticed through creation.
Not only does Alison Chao appear human, the
use of SCP-268 - a newsboy cap that causes
the wearer to become unnoticed - allows her
to walk anywhere throughout creation without
being detected.
But most importantly of all, the Hidden child
is said to be the one who opens the way for
the Scarlet King’s entrance into our dimension.
And Alison Chao has access to the Wanderer’s
Library: An unfettered access point between
dimensions.
If one of the infinite Alisons was the secret
daughter of the Scarlet King, would the Wanderer’s
Library not be a perfect way for him to leave
his own dimension and enter ours?
She could be the final piece he needs, Hidden
under the nose of the Foundation and the Serpent’s
Hand, making all the secret power plays to
allow for the Scarlet King’s eventual bloody
revenge on our world.
Unless, of course, SCP-999 - the family disappointment
- stops him first.
We realize that some of these theories may
seem surprising, but when it comes to the
anomalous - especially the Scarlet King - the
only thing you can ever expect is the unexpected.
Do you agree with our theories?
If not, who do you think are the children
of the Scarlet King?
Let us know down in the comments.
One thing is for certain: We hope we never
meet any of this terrible tyrant’s nasty
children.
Except the Tickle Monster, of course.
He can hang with us any time.
Now check out “SCP-001 - The Scarlet King”
and “SCP-999 - The Tickle Monster” for
more information about the Scarlet King and
his misfit Children.